The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, in that
case, let's go on.
At the end of last
class, we were
beginning to talk about
the Doppler shift.
And we defined our terms.
And I guess I'll repeat the
definitions on the blackboard
here.
We are talking initially about
the case where the observer is
stationary and the source is
moving with velocity v. We
are talking
initially about sound
waves, waves which have a fixed
speed relative to some medium.
And the speed relative to
the medium will be called u.
v will be the
velocity of recession,
as shown on the diagram.
Delta t sub s, s for source,
will be the time interval
between wave crests as measured
at the source-- so period
of wave at source.
And delta t sub o
will be the period
of the wave at the observer.
And what we're
trying to calculate
is the relationship
between delta t sub o
and delta t sub s.
OK, at this point, I'd
like to go to the screen
and go through the
different stages of what
happens as this
process takes place.
We start in frame
one with an observer
in some location, a source
at some different location.
Source is moving to the right.
Source is emitting
the first wave crest
in this slide number one.
Nothing too interesting so far.
Next picture, the source
emits the second wave crest.
But meanwhile, the
source has moved.
The time between wave
crests as seen by the source
is delta t sub s.
So the distance that the source
will move during that time
integral is v times
delta t sub s.
And we'll call that delta l.
And this really is
the important slide.
I think I have it
highlighted here.
That picture is what really
counts for the whole Doppler
shift.
It says that the
second wave crest
has to travel a little further
than the first wave crest
by this amount delta l.
So delta l will be
the crucial quantity
that will control the answer.
Third slide, the
waves have traveled.
Now the first crest
in this third frame
has just hit the observer.
Next frame, the last
crest, the second crest,
has hit the observer.
And to figure out
the Doppler shift
from those images,
all we have to do
is realize that if both
objects were stationary,
there'd be no time difference
between observation and source.
Each could occur later by
some fixed amount, the amount
of time it would take
the sound wave to travel.
But they will occur
later by the same amount
if there was no motion.
So if there's no
motion, delta t sub o
would be equal to delta t sub
s, if there was no motion.
But because there
is motion, we said
that the wave, the
second crest, is
going to have to travel
further by the amount delta l.
So it'll be delayed
by the amount of time
it takes for the wave
to travel delta l.
And that's just delta
l divided by v--
so plus delta l divided by v.
And we know what delta l is.
Delta l is just v
times delta t sub s.
I'm sorry, this is divided by u.
u is the speed of the wave.
v is the speed of the source.
So here we have in the
numerator v times delta t sub s,
and the denominator is u.
This is just what
we said delta l is.
So this really is our result.
It tells us what delta o is
in terms of delta t sub s.
And we can solve for the ratio.
It tells us that delta
t sub o over delta t
sub s is equal to
1 plus v over u.
Solve that equation.
Now there's a
standard definition
that's used to describe
redshifts, which
is that this ratio, which is
also the ratio of wavelengths,
which is how I
usually think of it,
the wavelength at the
observer divided by the wave
length at the source--
the wave length
being disproportional
to the delta t.
The wave ones are just the
wave speed times delta t.
This is defined to
be 1 plus z where
z is what's called the redshift.
And the astronomers
take out the one
so that if both objects are
stationary, z is equal to 0.
That corresponds
to know redshift.
That means the wave length
is the same at the source
and at the observer.
So the ratio of the
wavelength as its observed
to the wavelength of the source
is what's called 1 plus z.
So in this case, it
follows immediately
that the redshift for this
case is just v over u.
So maybe I'll just write that
again in a box and label it.
z is equal to v
over u corresponds
to the nonrelativistic case,
or the sound wave case,
with the source moving.
OK?
Everybody on board?
Any questions?
OK, straightforward
enough, I think.
OK, now we will go on to do the
alternative simple case, where
the observer is moving and
the source is stationary.
So keep the source on the right
and the observer on the left.
But this time it's the observer
that's moving again with speed
v. So v is always for these
two cases in my notation
the relative velocity between
the source and the observer.
So now we have a new
sequence of pictures.
So first picture again
is fairly trivial.
The first wave crest is
being emitted by the source.
Picture number two,
the second wave crest
is emitted by the source.
Picture number three,
the first wave crest
arrives at the source.
And picture number four
now, the second wave crest
arrives at the source.
And for this case,
it is this last frame
where all the action is.
The point is that between the
time when the first crest hits
the source and the time
when the second crest hits
the source, that is the time
between the third and fourth
frame, the source has moved.
And it's moved by
distance which is
v times the time
between those images.
And the time
between these images
is just the time that
the source experiences
between the receipt
of the two waves.
And it's therefore what we've
been calling delta t sub
o, the time interval as
measured by the observer.
So the distance traveled
is just v times t sub o.
And it's that last frame inside
that box where all the action
happens for determining the
answer for this problem.
So we can put that
into equations also.
This time it's slightly
more complicated.
It starts basically
with the same idea.
Delta t sub o is
equal to delta t sub
s, which is what it would
be if there was no motion.
But it's a little bit longer
because of the extra distance
the second pulse travels.
And that extra distance
is again called delta l.
So the time delay is again delta
l divided by u, the wave speed.
But this time we have a
different formula for delta l.
This time delta l is v times
delta t sub 0, instead of
last time it was v
times delta t sub s.
So this time the equation
is ever so slightly more
complicated, because
delta t sub 0
appears on both sides
of the equation.
Last time we
immediately wrote down
an equation for delta t sub o.
But nonetheless, this is one
equation with one unknown,
so of course it's trivial to
solve it for delta t sub o.
And when we do that,
we get delta t sub o.
I'll maybe divide
by delta t sub s.
By just doing a little
bit of algebra on that,
you discover it's 1
minus u over v inverse.
And then z, the redshift, is
delta t sub 0 over delta t sub
s minus 1 by definition.
AUDIENCE: Is that
1 minus v over u?
PROFESSOR: Oh, do I
have it wrong here?
Yes, it's 1 minus v over u.
Thank you very much.
Right, coming from
the v over u here,
obviously, as you noticed.
OK, so to write down a
final equation for z,
it's delta t0 over
delta t sub s minus 1.
So it's 1 minus v over
u inverse minus 1.
And then just putting things
over our common denominator,
it ends up being v over u
divided by 1 minus v over u.
And that then is
our final answer.
So this now is the answer for
the nonrelativistic case--
again, we haven't
done relativity yet--
and the observer moving.
OK, now it's worth
pointing out that when
velocity is small compared
to the wave speed,
as is often the
case if we're going
to be talking about
light which we'll
be talking about in
a minute, but could
be the case with respect
to sound as well.
Then these two formulas
are almost the same.
They're both
proportional to v over u,
when I'm talking about
the case where v over u
is a small quantity, where
the motion is slow compared
to the sound speed
or wave speed.
And the only difference
is that denominator.
Here we have a denominator
of 1 minus v over u.
And here the v over
u is the whole show.
There's no denominator.
And if v over u is small, the
denominator is close to 1.
So the two answers are
going to be almost the same.
And one can describe that a
little bit more succinctly
perhaps, by saying that z with
the observer moving minus z
with the source moving is equal
to v over u quantity squared
times 1 minus v over
u in the denominator.
Just a little bit of
algebra to get that result.
And what that
shows explicitly is
that second order in v over u.
It's proportional to v over
u squared, not to v over u.
So if v over u were
a part in 1,000,
the difference would
be a part in a million.
So for slow
velocities, it doesn't
matter whether it's the
source that's moving
or the observer that's moving.
But these answers
can, of course,
be very different if the
velocity v is comparable to u.
OK, any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this violate
Galilean relativity?
PROFESSOR: Does it violate
Not really.
Although, one has to maybe be
careful about how one defines
Galilean relativity.
What makes it legitimate
as a classical mechanical
calculation is that
unshown, but crucially
important on the
blackboard, is the air
that the sound wave
is moving through.
So in one of these pictures,
the air was at rest.
The other picture,
the air was moving.
Or rather, well,
I said that wrong.
The air was at rest
in both pictures.
But if you want to make
a Galilean transformation
to relate one
picture to the other,
then after you've made the
Galilean transformation,
the air would be moving
and it would not really
be the same picture.
So it is all consistent
with Galilean relativity.
And one has to remember
that the air is
playing a crucial role here.
When we say that the observer
or the source is at rest,
the full sentence
really is that it's
at rest relative to the medium
that's transporting the wave.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This is not
really a question, just
kind of an observation.
I just find it interesting
that in the case
if v is greater than u that
this one is always positive,
no problem.
But if v is greater than
u in the other case,
then you have a
negative number, which,
I don't know if that--
I just find that weird.
PROFESSOR: Right, let me think.
If v is greater than u, then
the observer moving case
becomes negative.
And it presumably means
the wave never reaches it.
If the observer is moving
faster than the wave speed,
the wave never reaches them.
And that's why the
answer is peculiar.
If the source is moving
faster than the wave speed,
the wave still
reaches the observer.
So there is a nontrivial and
believable answer in that case.
OK.
What we're going to move on to
now is the relativistic case.
And as I think I described in
the course handouts, relativity
is has sort of an odd
role in this class.
We need a little
bit of relativity.
But at the same time, there
are the courses in relativity.
So I don't want this to
be a course in relativity.
In the old days,
when there weren't so
many other courses
in relativity,
we did in fact spend two
weeks of this course doing
special relativity.
But I don't think that's
worthwhile anymore.
Well, I'll maybe ask
for a show of hands.
How many of you
have had relativity
in some other course?
That's what I thought, most
of you, perhaps not all.
Well, maybe I should
ask the other question.
How many of you have
not had relativity?
OK, a number.
So I do want to make
the course completely
intelligible to the people
in that second group.
Special relativity is not a
prerequisite for this class.
So what my goal will be
to tell you enough special
relativity so that you'll be
able to follow what comes next.
But I will not be
driving those results.
I'll just leave
for other courses
for people who
want to take them.
And if you don't want to
take them, that's fine too.
But I want to make
this course coherent.
So what we're going to do
is discuss the consequences
of special relativity
without trying
to relate those
consequences directly
to the underlying ideas
of special relativity.
I will, however, mention where
special relativity comes from.
It arose in the mind
of Albert Einstein,
because he realized that the
physics that we knew well,
basically Newtonian
physics at that time,
possess this property, Galilean
relativity, which came up
in a question just a minute ago.
Galilean relativity
says that if you
look at any given physical
process in a frame that's
moving at a uniform velocity
relative to the first frame
that you use to describe
it, it should also
be consistent with the laws of
physics in the second frame.
Incidentally, I-- maybe I'm
more ignorant about history
than most-- only learned
a few years ago what
Galileo had to do with this.
It did actually play
a very important role
in the history of
Galileo in the physics
that he was debating about.
A key issue in the
time of Galileo
was whether the earth moved
around the sun or the sun moved
around the earth.
And that was something Galileo
was intensely involved in.
And one of the
arguments that said
that it must be the
sun that moves--
it can't be the
earth that moves--
was that if it's the
earth that moves,
it means we move at
very high velocity.
The velocity of the
earth around the sun
is high by ordinary standards.
And obviously, we'd feel
that motion, people thought.
So it was a proof
that it must be
that the earth is stationary
and the sun moves.
Because otherwise, we'd feel
the effect of this high velocity
motion.
So it was crucial to
Galileo's point of view
that it was really
the earth that
was moving that you
don't detect motion.
If you're in uniform
motion, the laws of physics
are exactly the same as they
would be if you were at rest.
And that's basically
what Galilean relativity
is all about.
And it was in fact very
clearly enunciated by Galileo
in his writings.
So that was the
case for mechanics.
But at the same
time, in the 1860s,
Maxwell invented
Maxwell's equations,
or completed them is maybe
a more accurate description
for what Maxwell really did.
Most of those equations
already existed.
And a prediction of
Maxwell's equations
is that light travels at
some fixed speed, which
could be calculated in terms
of epsilon naught and mu
naught that appeared in
those equations, a speed
that we call c.
Now if light travels
at speed c, it
would mean that if you
got into a spaceship
and chased a light beam, it'd
say half the speed of light.
The implication of the physics
that was known at the time
would have been that,
from the point of view
of that spaceship traveling
at half the speed of light,
the light pulse would
only be receding
at half the speed of light.
You would have half
caught up with it.
But that would mean that from
the frame of this rapidly
moving spaceship,
the laws of physics
must somehow be different.
Maxwell's equations must not
hold in their standard form.
So there was this tension
between Maxwell and Newton,
if you like.
The tension was not
a contradiction.
It would be perfectly
possible for there
to be a fixed frame in which
Maxwell's equations had
their simple form.
But Newton's equations
could perhaps
have the same form
in all frames.
And that in fact was what
people thought at the time.
To account for this situation,
physicists invented the idea
of an ether which was a medium
through which light waves
travelled, similar to the air
in which sound waves traveled.
And the frame in which Maxwell's
equations had their simple form
was the rest frame of the ether.
And if you moved relative
ether, the equations
would be different.
And that's what people
thought in 1904.
And it was a consistent
point of view,
but it meant that there
was this dichotomy
between electromagnetism
and mechanics.
So Einstein thought maybe
physics is not so sloppy.
Maybe there's a more elegant
way which all this plays out.
And he realized that if you
modified the equations that
are used to transform between
one frame and another,
you could make Maxwell's
equations frame invariant.
You could make it so
that Maxwell's equations
are valid in all frames.
And if we go back to our
example of the spaceship chasing
the light beam, with these
new transformation equations
that Einstein suggested,
it would turn out,
even though it's very
contrary to intuition,
that when the spaceship measures
the speed of the light pulse,
it would still measure that
the light pulse was moving away
at speed c, even though it
had moved at half c trying
to catch up with
the light pulse.
So it's not obvious
how that can happen.
But it turns out it can happen.
We'll be talking a little bit
more about how it happens.
And that was basically
Einstein's proposal.
It was a proposal that
there is no ether,
that the laws of physics both
electromagnetism and mechanics
are the same in all frames.
And in order to do
that, he had to say
that the equations
of transformation
between one frame
and another are
different from what
Galileo believed.
So these are what we call
the Lorentz transformations.
We might write them down
later in the course,
but we're not going to
write them down today.
But what goes into them
are three physical effects,
which we will talk about.
If we're talking about
the time dilation,
we only need one of
those three effects.
So I'm going to start by just
discussing that for a minute,
and then we'll come back at the
end of the class, or perhaps
next class, depending
on how timing works out,
to discuss the other
two primary effects that
are needed to make up the
theory of special relativity
and explain how it could
be that the speed of light
could look the same
to all observers,
even if we're talking about
observers that might be moving.
OK, so time dilation
is the simple statement
that if I were to
watch a moving clock,
the moving clock would appear
to me to be running slower.
I'll just mention
for a moment now
that I put the word
appear in quotation marks.
That means we're going to come
back and discuss in detail
what is meant by
the word appear.
But to finish the
sentence first,
the moving clock would appear
to me in my reference frame
to always be running slower.
And so by a very predictable
amount, a famous expression
in special relativity,
gamma, where
gamma is 1 over the
square root of 1
minus beta squared, where beta
is just an abbreviation for v
over c, the velocity
of the clock
divided by the speed of light.
So as long as v over c is
small, this is a small effect.
Gamma is near 1.
And running slowly
by a factor of 1
means not running slowly at all.
So the fact it was near 1
means it's a very small effect.
But moving clocks will always
appear to be running slower.
That's one of these three
effects of special relativity
that we'll be discussing in the
course of lecture notes one.
Now let me come back now
to talk about this word
"appear," because that's
a little bit subtle.
Might just add that
there was a series-- this
is just an aside-- but I
guess broadcast last year
there was a four-part
series of Brian Greene's
Fabric of the Cosmos that
was broadcast on PBS.
And the interesting thing about
that, which is relevant here,
is that he tried to
illustrate time dilation.
And he did it by having sort
of a parable of a person
sitting in a chair
and somebody else
carrying a clock over
his head, walking
towards the person
sitting in the chair.
And the camera showed what the
person sitting in the chair
would see and showed the
clock running slowly.
That's wrong.
It's not what he
would actually see.
And that's the crucial issue
of the word "appear" here.
When we say that the clock
appears to run slowly,
we're not talking about what
an observer would actually see.
The complication
of literally seeing
is that when you see
something, what you're doing
is you're measuring the
light pulses as they arrive
at your eyes at a given time.
And since light has
a finite travel time,
it means that you're
seeing different things
at different times.
In particular, if there's
a large object coming
towards you, say this laser
pointer coming towards me,
I would be seeing
the front of it
at an earlier time than I
would be seeing the back of it.
The other way around, actually.
I'd be seeing the back
at an earlier time,
because the light that leaves
here at an earlier time
would take longer to
reach my eye, reach my eye
the same time as light which
leaves the front of the object
later.
So the point is that as
this is coming toward me,
I'm seeing different
pieces of it
at different times in terms
of the actual existence
of this laser pointer.
And that makes
things complicated.
So what you actually see
when you take into account
special relativity is
fairly complicated.
You can calculate
it, but there's
no simple expression for it.
You really just have
to calculate point
by point what you'll be seeing
for every part of the object
at a given time,
nothing very simple.
So the simple expression,
which just says,
clocks run slowly by
a factor of gamma,
and we'll learn
later e expressions
about how things
contract and how
simultaneity changes,
those simple expressions
are not based on what any
observer would actually see.
But rather, they're
based on what
ends up giving a simpler
picture, a picture in which you
imagine that what
we're discussing
is not what an individual
sees but rather what
a frame of reference sees.
So we're talking not about
what the observer sees
but rather what is seen in the
observer's frame of reference.
And a frame of
reference, I think
you could think of it
pretty concretely, as kind
of a structure of rulers
connected together
to each other to
form a grid of rulers
and with clocks located
everywhere along this grid.
So all the observations
are made locally.
That is, if you want to measure
a time in a given reference
frame, you don't use a
central clock, waiting
for the light pulse to
reach that central clock.
Rather, you measure
the reference frame
is filled with
clocks, all of which
have been synchronized
to start with.
And if you want to know
what time an event happens,
you look at the clock
that's next to it.
And that clock tells you what
time that event happened.
So that's typically
what we draw when
we draw a coordinate
systems and so on.
It's really the way
we normally think.
The point is,
though, if you really
want to think what one
observer would see,
it's more complicated.
Then you have to take into
account the light travel time.
So it's only after you take
out the way travel time
and calculate how local
clocks would compare
that you see this time
dilation in the simple form,
that the clock
always runs slower.
So in particular,
for this example
of the person sitting
in a chair and the clock
coming towards them,
that's exactly what
we're going to be talking about.
That is the Doppler shift.
And what we'll find is when
the clock comes towards them,
he will see the
blueshift not a redshift.
He'll see the clock
running faster not slower,
the opposite of what was
shown in the TV program.
But the difference
is that what causes
it to look like
it's going faster
is the fact that each pulse
travels a shorter distance
if the clock is coming
towards the observer.
And that becomes a bigger
effect than the fact
the clock itself, if it were
measured relative to clocks
that it passes, would
be running slowly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in that case,
if the clock, let's say,
was moving toward
you really fast,
could you measure it when it was
directly perpendicular to you?
And then that would be the
special relativity time
dilation?
PROFESSOR: Well, if it
was moving alongside you.
If it was coming right at
you, it would just hit you.
And that was the case,
Sonya, more or less.
But yes, you're exactly right.
If the clock were moving at
right angles to the observer
so that the observer
saw it, what you really
want for this to
be the pure effect
is you want to have the
velocity of the clock
to be perpendicular to
the velocity of the photon
that the observer is seeing,
as measured in the observer's
reference frame.
Actually that matters.
Then you see would see
pure time dilation effect.
That's exactly right.
OK, so might just add that Brian
Green and a bunch of people
here at MIT, actually--
I was involved
and so were some others.
There's a number of MIT
people on this program.
So we ended up having
a long conversation
with Brian Green
about it by email.
And everybody at MIT thought
it was just plain wrong.
Brian Green actually
took the position
that it was very
intentional on his part,
and he was just trying to
illustrate the time dilation
effect, and he didn't want to
talk about the Doppler shift.
And since he didn't
want to talk about it,
he could ignore the
fact that it was there.
We all thought that
was bad pedagogy.
But we never convinced
Brian, I should say.
OK, now what we want to do is
go through these Doppler shift
calculations again,
this time recognizing
that moving clocks run
slowly by a factor of gamma.
So we're now going to be doing
the relativistic case where
the wave is sound
waves-- excuse me,
where the wave is light waves.
I'll get this straight.
And the velocities might
be comparable to the speed
of light.
So this time dilation
effect is large
enough so that we want
to take it into account.
Now in this case,
what we are hoping,
and everything would be wrong,
inconsistent, if we can find
this, we're hoping
that in this case,
the two answers
should be the same.
It shouldn't matter whether
the source is moving
or the observer is moving.
Earlier it did matter, and
we said that was explicable,
because we knew that
air was involved.
And if we made a
velocity transformation
to go from one
picture to the other,
from the picture where the
source is moving to the picture
where the observer
was moving, the air
would have a different
velocity in the two pictures.
It would be stationary in
one and moving in the other.
So we would not expect
to get the same answer
as we would have gotten
assuming the air was stationary.
But in this case, if anything
has a different velocity when
you go from the picture
where the source is moving
to the picture where
the observer is moving,
it would have to be the ether
that has a different velocity.
But the basic axiom
of special relativity
is that there is
no ether, at least
there's no physical effects
coming from the ether.
So you might as well
pretend it does not exist.
You can't really
prove that it does not
exist if it has no properties.
It still exists.
But the basic axiom
of special relativity
is that there are
no physical effects
coming from this either.
So for special relativity, we
should get the same answer,
whether it's the
source that's moving
or the observer that's moving.
It's really the same
situation, just viewed
in different reference frames.
And special relativity says it
cannot matter what reference
frame we're doing
the calculations in.
So it's the same
pictures, but this time we
want to take into account the
fact that moving clocks run
slowly by a factor of gamma.
So looking at these
pictures, we can first
start just glancing
at them and saying,
where's there a
clock that's moving?
That might be something
we need to think about.
And maybe I'll ask you--
which of these four frames
shows a moving clock?
AUDIENCE: All of them?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: All of
them, I guess so.
But the time interval
measured on the clock
is only actually
relevant to one of them.
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two, exactly, two.
Here we said that
the source is moving,
and we said the time measured
on the source's clock
between the emission of
these two wave crests.
Incidentally, we're
usually talking
about continuous waves
like light waves.
And then we're talking about
the time between successive wave
crests.
Well, if we just as well imagine
that the source is emitting
a series of pulses where
each pulse represents a wave
crest, and somehow to me
that sounds a little simpler
to describe, because
you don't have
to think about the sine wave
associated with the signal
that the source is
actually creating.
So in any case, the time
between these pulses,
I'll call them, as measured
by the source clock,
is what we call
delta t sub s, is
the time that the source
would actually measure.
And the source is
moving in this picture.
So relative to
our frame, we want
to think of this entire
series of pictures
as all being consistent
in our frame.
It's very important, since
transformations between frames
are a little complicated
in special relativity.
It's very important when
you're doing any problem
to pick what frame you're going
to use for your description
and be sure to stick to it.
If anything is initially
described in another frame,
you have to figure out what
it looks like in your frame
in order to fit it together
with the other events
that you're describing in your
own particular reference frame.
So for this problem,
our frame will
be the frame of the
slide, the frame, which
is at rest relative
to the observer.
So we could also call
it the observer's frame.
And relative to that frame,
the source is moving.
And therefore, the
clock-- a source
is emitting a series of pulses.
That's a clock.
Anything that does anything at
regular intervals is a clock.
So the source represents
a moving clock.
And we need to take into account
the fact that the source will
be running slowly by
a factor of gamma.
And otherwise, nothing changes.
The observer has a clock
also, which the observer
is going to use to measure
the time between crests.
But the observer's clock
is at rest in our frame.
So there's no time dilation
associated with the observer's
clock, only a time
dilation associated
with the clock on the source.
So again, the important issue
is all inside that yellow box.
And what do I do now is
look at the equations
and see how the
equations are modified.
I guess I should start
back at the beginning
of the blackboards.
Maybe I should turn
the blackboard lights
on when I work on
the blackboard.
So the time integral
as seen by the observer
will be equal to--
last time we just
had delta t sub s as our first
term, which would be what it
would be if there
was no velocity.
And that's still true if
there was no velocity.
But if the clock is going
to be running slowly
by a factor of gamma, that would
mean that the time interval
that we would
measure, even if there
was no change in path length,
which will be the next term,
if there was no
change in path length,
the time that we would
measure as the observer would
be different from
the time interval
as measured by the source
by a factor of gamma.
But one has to figure out
whether the gamma goes
in the numerator
or the denominator.
And sometimes it's
a little tricky.
It helps a lot, I think, to
just sort of imagine an example.
Any example is
clear, it turns out.
But when you try to write
down the answer in general,
you sometimes get it wrong.
That's my experience with
myself and with other people.
So this clock is wanting slower.
And say we're talking about
a second time interval.
If this clock is running slower,
it means it takes longer for it
to take off a second.
We would see it as maybe running
slower by a factor of two.
It would mean that it
would only take off
a second every two seconds.
So that means that the time
interval that we would see--
and that's what we're
trying to calculate,
the time interval
as the observer--
is going to be longer than delta
t sub s by a factor of gamma.
So the first term changes
from what it was before.
And what we're doing is we're
rewriting this equation.
So the first term
changes from what
it was before by putting in a
factor of gamma in front of it.
Because the source
clock is running slowly.
And then the second term is
still delta l divided by u.
But the equation for
delta l changes also,
because delta l is
the time interval
that it takes for the light
to travel the extra distance,
where the extra
distance was because
of the time between the clicks.
And that is now changed
because of the time
dilation of the source clock.
So the second term also
changes by a factor of gamma.
So it's gamma
times delta t sub s
plus v times gamma times
delta t sub s divided by u.
So the whole answer just
changes by a factor of gamma.
So it's gamma times 1 plus v
over c times delta t sub s.
And now if you do a
little bit of arithmetic
here-- gamma, remember, is
1 over the square root of 1
minus v squared over c squared.
And a squared minus
b squared-- I'm now
thinking of the denominator 1
minus v squared over c squared.
Maybe I'll write
this on the side.
1 minus v squared
over c squared--
it's worth remembering here--
can be written as 1 plus v over
c times 1 minus v over c.
And we have the square
root of that appearing here
in the denominator.
Gamma is 1 over the
square root of this.
So this becomes the square
root in the denominator,
resulting the square
root of 1 plus v
over c appearing in the answer.
And this remains
in the denominator.
And what we get simplifies
to simply 1 plus beta over 1
minus beta inside the square
root times delta t sub s.
So this is the special
relativity answer,
the relativistic answer, and
this is for the source moving.
Now we expect that the
answer won't depend on
whether the source
is moving or not,
but certainly the
calculations do.
So this is what we got from the
calculation, which we assumed
that it was a source
that was moving,
and the observer was stationary.
It's just corrected
from the previous answer
by this factor of gamma.
Any questions about that?
OK, so to summarize on
the slide what's changed
is that this time interval,
this extra distance delta l
for the relativistic
problem, is not
v times delta t sub s as it was.
But rather what we said is
that it's gamma times v times
delta s, because the
clock on the source
is running slowly by
a factor of gamma.
And it was this
difference that we just
used on the calculation
on the blackboard
to get the new answer.
OK now the next
calculation, now we're
going to do the same
calculation again,
which we already did for
the nonrelativistic case.
But this time it will
be the observer moving.
And we're going to try to
do the relativistic case.
So this time it's
the clock carried
by the observer
that's running slowly.
And remember, this
is running slowly
relative to us, relative to
our frame of reference, where
our frame of reference is
by definition the frame
of reference of the slide
that we're looking at.
Source is stationary,
so delta t sub
s is just an honest time
as we would measure it.
But times as measured by
the observer, delta t sub o,
are going to be different.
So to correct the
calculation for relativity,
that's the crucial
box as it was even
in the nonrelativistic case.
And we're going
to have to change
that equation by
replacing delta l.
Instead of v times delta t sub
0 is v times delta t prime.
Now delta t prime is not
exactly delta t sub 0
or gamma times delta t sub 0.
It's a little trickier.
Let's see.
Hold on.
The definition I want
to use for delta t prime
is that it's the
time as measured
between the third frame
and the fourth frame.
But it's the time
as we measure it.
I still want to
describe everything
in terms of the way
we would measure it.
So delta t sub prime
is not measured either
by the source or the observer.
It's measured by us.
And it's related to the time as
the observer would measure it
by a factor of gamma,
because relative to us,
the observer's clock is running
slowly by a factor of gamma.
AUDIENCE: So we're the source?
PROFESSOR: Well,
we're stationary
relative to the source, because
the source is stationary.
But we're the frame of
reference of the slide,
is the way I like
to think about it.
But it is the
frame of reference,
same as the frame of
reference as the source.
That's right.
So delta t sub 0 is
related to delta t
sub prime by a factor of gamma.
And again, one has
to think a little bit
to make sure one gets the
gamma in the right place,
the numerator or
the denominator.
We're saying that the
observer clock appears
to be running slowly
relative to us.
And that means that
during the amount of time
it would take for it to
say take off one second,
since it's running slowly,
should take more than a
second relative to us.
And that's what this
formula would give,
if we multiply by gamma.
It would say that delta t
prime is equal to gamma times
delta t sub 0.
So we would say that the time
that the observer clock ticks
off one second we might
measure two seconds.
That's the direction
of the time shift,
all given by that formula.
And those are all the pictures.
Now we just have to write
down the equations that
go with those pictures.
And the hope is that
we'll get the same answer
as we got last time.
I think I'll leave
that on the board.
Let's see.
What do I do?
No, I won't leave
it on the board.
OK, this time the
calculation we're mimicking
is the calculation up here.
This was the calculation we had
for the nonrelativistic case
where the observer was moving.
Now we want to put in
the time dilation that
would correct that calculation.
And the key equation is
that the time interval
between the receipt
of the two wave crests
as we would measure
it, which is why
I call it delta t
sub prime, so prime
is not the source
or the observer.
It's us.
It's the same frame of
reference as the source,
but the source
isn't located there.
So we think of it
as the time interval
as measured in the
frame of reference.
That's the frame of the
slide, which is our frame.
And it is equal to
gamma times delta t sub
0, where delta t sub 0 is
the time as it would actually
be measured on the
observer's clock.
So, we're keeping
their labels s and 0
to mean what would
actually be measured
on the clocks at the
source and at the observer.
That's what we're
trying to establish
a relationship between.
So the basic formula
that we have up
top there would first
become delta t sub 0
is equal to-- hold on.
Now actually, we would
not start by writing down
an equation for delta t sub 0.
Rather what we
want to do is start
by writing down the
relationship as we would see it
in our frame, which is going
involve delta t sub prime.
We'll worry about
delta t sub 0 later.
So our equation
is going to become
delta t prime is equal to
delta t sub s plus v times
delta t sub prime divided
by the wave speed,
which now we'll
call c, since we're
doing a relativistic problem.
So this is the basic
equation for the time delay
as we would see it in our frame,
where delta t sub prime is
the time between the receipt
of the first and second crests,
the time between
frames three and four
as we would measure it.
And now we can do the same
thing that we did over there,
first for delta t sub prime.
And we discover that
delta t sub prime
can be written as 1
minus v over c inverse,
just doing algebra on this
equation, times delta t sub s.
So that equation relates delta
t prime to delta t sub s.
And now we use the
equation up top here
to see what the observer
himself would actually measure.
And that becomes just 1 over
gamma times delta t sub prime.
So delta t sub observed is
equal to 1 over gamma times 1
minus v over c inverse
times delta t sub source.
And now since it's important
we get the same answer,
I'm going to write in
some intermediate algebra
here just so we can all
really see that it works out.
The 1 over gamma, I am going
to write as-- remember gamma is
1 over the square root
of 1 minus beta squared--
so 1 over gamma is the square
root of 1 minus beta squared.
And I'm going to write that
as the square root of 1
plus beta times 1 minus beta.
So this is the
factor 1 over gamma.
Now we have explicitly here a
factor of 1 over 1 minus beta.
The inverse makes it 1 over.
Did I write something wrong?
AUDIENCE: From the second
until the third time?
PROFESSOR: Second to
third, you're there?
AUDIENCE: I thought it wasn't--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
goes to the other side.
It is minus.
OK, finally, the 1
minus beta, you see
occurs to the first
power in the denominator.
And the 1/2 power
to the numerator.
So we do indeed get
exactly what we wanted.
Delta t sub 0 is equal
to the square root of 1
plus beta divided by 1 minus
beta times delta t sub s.
And now we know that this
is the relativistic answer
for either source
or observer moving.
And then if we want to
write down what z is,
this is delta t observer divided
by delta t source minus 1.
So that becomes just
the square root of 1
plus beta over 1
minus beta minus 1.
So we found what
we expected, what
we wanted to find to be
consistent with the basic ideas
of relativity.
It's the same answer
no matter which
one is moving, because
it doesn't matter
what frame of reference
we do the calculation in.
OK, questions about either
the calculations or the ideas
behind them?
OK in that case, let's move on.
I do want to come back and
talk about the other two
kinematic effects of
special relativity, which
are Lorentz contraction
and a change
in the notion of simultaneity.
But before I get
to that, there's
one other issue I
want to discuss first,
mainly because it's something
you need to understand
to do the problem set
that's due tomorrow.
And that is the
situation that's needed
to describe clocks which
might be accelerating.
Special relativity really only
describes inertial reference
frames and how things change
from one inertial frame
to another.
So if you know how
a clock behaves
if it's at rest in
one reference frame,
special relativity completely
dictates without any ambiguity
what it would look
like at a frame that
was moving at a
uniform velocity,
relative to the original frame,
which means it completely
dictates how that clock is
going to behave if it is moving
at a constant uniform velocity.
But nonetheless,
in the real world,
we have very few clocks around
that are completely inertial.
Every clock that
we see around us
from the clock on
the wall, which
is moving with the earth or my
wrist watch which moves more,
is constantly undergoing
accelerations.
So we want to be able
to talk about clocks
which are accelerating.
So we need to say a little
bit about how we would do that
and how we do it if the clocks
were moving at relativistic
speeds , which also happens
with satellites, for example.
The GPS system as you've
probably been told
wouldn't actually work
unless the calculations were
done in such a sophisticated
way that they even
take into account the
effects of general relativity
as well special relativity.
So moving clocks
and how they behave
is a crucially important
topic technologically.
So what do we say that a
clock that's accelerating?
There's I think a common myth
that to describe acceleration
you need general
relativity, and therefore we
have to put off talking
about accelerating clocks
until we take a course
in general relativity.
That's actually totally false.
What general relativity does
is provide a theory of gravity
which basically says the gravity
and acceleration are intimately
linked.
And that's where
acceleration gets
pushed into general relativity.
But special relativity
alone is enough for us
to describe any system that
could be described by equations
that are consistent
with special relativity.
Special relativity does
not describe gravity.
So in any situation where
gravity is important,
special relativity is at a
loss to make real predictions
about what should happen.
But as long as gravity is
absent, as long as we're only
dealing with
electromagnetic forces
that we think we
understand, there's
nothing that prevents
us from using
the equations of
special relativity
to describe what happens.
We have to use the dynamical
equations of special relativity
that talk about how
things respond to forces.
And whenever there's a force,
there's an acceleration.
But there really
are such equations.
We can combine, for
example, electromagnetism
with relativistic mechanics to
describe a system of particles
that are interacting
electromagnetically, completely
consistent with
special relativity.
And even those particles
are accelerating,
we could say everything
we want to say about them.
So in particular, if
there's a physical clock,
to the extent that we could
describe that clock as made out
of particles whose
physics we understand,
special relatively
will still tell us
what that clock will do even
when that clock accelerates.
The answer, however, from that
calculation, you might imagine,
is very, very complicated.
Because the physics
of any actual clock,
my wrist watch as an example,
is pretty damn complicated.
And we're not really
going to write down
the equations that describe
my wrist watch to figure out
how it's going to behave
when it accelerates.
So what are we going to do?
Let me point out
that you already
have pretty much experience
with accelerating clocks,
because all of you--
well, many of you--
wear wrist watches like I
do that are accelerating
all the time.
And they tend to work.
You basically assume that even
though they're accelerating
they've been designed well
enough so they can withstand
the accelerations that
your wrist gives them
and still read the right time.
On the other hand, one could
imagine contrary situations.
Probably my wrist watch
would survive this,
but if you take a mechanical
clock, a windup clock,
and heave it against
the wall and let
it smash against the
wall and come to a stop,
as it smashes
against the wall, it
wanted to go a very
large acceleration.
And if the acceleration
is large enough,
we can predict the effect
it will have the clock, even
though it's a
complicated interaction.
If the acceleration
is large enough,
it'll simply break the
clock and it will stop.
And that's one possible
effect that acceleration
can have a clock.
And other effects are
similar in nature.
If there's any effect
that the motion of my hand
has on the wrist watch, it
would be a mechanical effect
that you'd calculate
by understanding
the mechanics of
how the watch works,
not by understanding
any principles
of general relativity.
What's at stake
underlying this--
you might wonder what
the real difference is--
special relativity can make
precise predictions about how
a clock will behave if it
moves at a uniform velocity,
even without knowing
anything about the details
of that clock.
Special relativity could
make that prediction
because there's a symmetry,
Lorentz symmetry, which
relates those two situations.
And that's an exact
symmetry of nature.
So no matter what the
clock is made out of,
if it's moving at
a uniform velocity,
special relativity
tells you there's
no doubt it would run
slowly by a factor of gamma.
On the other hand,
there's no such principle
of any kind, either
in special relativity
or general relativity,
about acceleration.
So if you want to know
the effect of acceleration
on a clock, it really depends
in detail on how large
the acceleration is of
course and the detailed
physics of the clock and how
much acceleration it takes
to effect it and in what
way it affects, precisely.
So what's the bottom line?
The bottom line is
that when we want
to talk about an accelerated
clock, which we really
do all the time, what
we always do is simply
assume that the clock
is built well enough
so that the acceleration
does not affect its speed.
And that really can be
said very precisely.
The assumption that
we're going to be making
is that these are
ideal clocks, meaning
that they're built well.
And when we say the
acceleration does not
affect the speed of the
clock, what we're saying
is that the clock will run
at precisely the same speed
as another clock that's,
say, moving instantaneously
alongside it with
the same velocity
but with no acceleration.
So at any point in the
motion of my arm here,
my wrist watch will have
some specific velocity.
The velocity will
affect in some tiny way
the speed of the clock by
this factor gamma, which
will be very close
to 1 for that case.
But we're going to assume, if
we call my watch an ideal clock,
that in the even time,
it will be running
at exactly the same speed
as a clock which is not
accelerating, but
which is moving
with the same velocity
as the wrist watch.
Therefore, the factor
of gamma will be there,
but there'll be no
effect of acceleration.
The speed of the clock
will be determined only
by its velocity relative
to our reference frame.
OK, is that clear enough?
And that's what you need to
assume about some accelerating
clocks that show up
on the problem set.
That's why I wanted
to get it in today.
OK, if there are no other
questions about that,
I'd like to come back and
talk a little bit more
about special relativity
and its consequences.
Sometime later in the course,
we'll talk a little bit more
about what I would call
the dynamical consequences
of special relativity,
which include
well known equations like e
equals mc squared, for example.
But before one talks
about energy and momentum,
which are quantities which
I will dub dynamical,
there kinematic effects
of special relativity
of which this time
dilation is one.
And by kinematic
I really just mean
the consequences of
special relativity
for the measurements
of times and distances.
And if one limits oneself
to discussing consequences
for times and distances,
kinematic consequences,
there really are precisely
three and no more consequences
of special relativity.
And really all special
relativity in some sense
is embodied by these
three statements
that we're going to be talking
about, the first of which
was time dilation, which
we've already seen.
I'll just remind you.
Time dilation says
that any clock which
is moving at speed d relative
to a given reference frame
will appear in quotation
marks to an observer using
that reference frame to run
slower than normal by a factor
denoted by the
Greek letter gamma.
Turn out the board lights
in case they're distracting.
And again, "appear" refers
not to how it would actually
look to any particular observer,
because any particular observer
in a particular
location is going
to be waiting for light
rays to reach that observer.
And they'll take
different amounts of time
depending on where they start.
"Appear" refers to measurements
made in the reference
frame of the observer,
where we assume
that all the actual measurements
are made by on the spot clocks
and rulers who measure
where the object actually
were at the time these
events happened and not
what it looks like at
sometime later when
light rays reach some observer.
OK, the second consequence,
and again all these
will involve the word "appear."
And I'll always write
it in quotation marks
to remind you that it's not
exactly what a person would
see.
The second one is another famous
effect of special relativity,
Lorentz contraction,
or sometimes called
Lorentz-Fitzgerald contraction.
Any rod which is moving at
a speed v along its length
relative to a given
reference frame
will appear-- and again
appear to an observer
using that reference
frame-- to be shorter
than its normal length by
the same factor, gamma.
A rod which is moving
perpendicular to its length
does not undo that change
in apparent length.
So these pictures
kind of show it all.
A rod, that bar is
the rod, a rod which
is moving at speed v
will look contracted,
will appear to be contracted,
by a factor of gamma.
And a rod which is
moving perpendicular
to its length, a rod which
is like this moving this way,
has no such effect, we'll appear
to have its natural length.
And this is a very
famous consequence
of special relativity.
It means that moving
rocket ships shorter
and shorter and faster
they go, and so on.
And again, you
should remember, it's
not what you'd actually see.
It's what you'd measure if you
had on the spot local observers
making these measurements,
which you then later compile.
OK, that's actually all I want
to say about the contraction.
Any questions?
OK, next and last is an effect
we just talked about less
because it's a little bit
more intricate to describe.
But the other crucially
important effect-- these
would not be consistent if
you didn't have all three.
The other crucially
important effect
is the changing simultaneity,
the relativity of simultaneity.
And it takes more
words describe it,
so there's more words on the
slide than on the other slides.
And the pictures are a little
bit more complicated too.
But the pictures do
say it all, really.
The point is that if you have a
system consisting of two clocks
which have been synchronized
in their own rest frame--
they're both at rest with
respect to each other
and they've been synchronized
in their own rest frame--
and they're connected
by say a rod,
which has some length which
we'll call l sub 0 in the rest
frame of the two clocks .
If that whole system
moves relative to us
by speed v along
the length, those
clocks, even though they were
synchronized in the rest frame,
would not look
synchronized to us
but rather would look like
they're out of synchronization.
And in particular, it will
look like the trailing clock,
the one on the back of
this combination of clocks,
will look a little bit
like it reads a little bit
later in the day
by a factor which
is beta times l sub 0 times c.
Beta remember is
v over c. l sub 0
is the distance
between the clocks
as measured in the rest
frame of the clocks.
And c is of course
the speed of light.
On the other hand,
if these two clocks
were moving in a
direction which is
perpendicular to the
line that joins them,
then there's no change
in the synchronization.
Now I should mention that
this really is crucially
important to the consistency
of the whole picture.
And actually showing that
the picture is consistent
is more than we're going to do.
It's not impossible to do
at this level by any means.
But it's more than we're
going to do in this class,
since we're not focusing
on special relativity.
But when you hear about
special relativity
and look at these
postulates, you
might realize that there seems
to be a pretty obvious tension
between the idea that
moving clocks run slowly
and that all
observers experience
the same laws of physics.
Because it means that if you
and I are moving with respect
to each other, I would
claim that your clock
was running slowly.
But at the same
time, you would claim
that my clock was
running slowly.
Because from your
point of view, you're
at some fixed velocity and
therefore an inertial frame.
And I'm moving relative to you.
So as you would describe it,
I would be a moving clock.
And my clock would
be running slowly.
So I think your clock
is running slowly.
You think my clock
That seems to contradict.
What happens if we hold the
clocks next to each other
and really just watch
how they compare?
Which one gets ahead?
How can we disagree on that?
Well of course, we can't hold
the clock next to each other
and also have them moving
relative to each other.
That's part of how you
get out of this conflict.
But let's think in a
little bit more detail
about what we're
really saying when
I say that your clock
is running slowly.
Remember, I want to
make all my observations
not by watching you, because
then there's this time delay
effect which complicates things.
I make all of my
observations by having
a family of local observers
surrounding me all at rest
relative to me.
And they report back to me.
And only when I receive
those reports and piece
them together do I
get the simple picture
of what happened
where when, which
is the simple picture
that is described
by these "appear" relationships.
So when I say your clock is
running slowly, what I mean
is that if I have a network
of clocks all at rest relative
to me, and your
clock comes shooting
by, I would measure what time
it reads as it goes past all
my local clocks.
Rather, they would measure
what time your clock reads
as it goes past
each local clock.
And then they would
all report back to me.
So if your clock is running
slowly, for example,
let's say by a factor
of two, it would
mean that when you're
clock passes my clock
and my clock reads one
second, your clock would only
read half a second, because
it's running slowly.
It hasn't ticked
off as much time.
When it passes some later clock
of my sequence of clocks, where
my clock reads two
seconds, your clock
will read one second, and so on.
So in that sense, I would say
your clock was running slowly.
Now that has to be
consistent with you thinking
that my clocks are all
running slowly as well.
So if you agree that my
clocks were all synchronized,
then you would conclude that
my clocks must be running fast.
Because when your clock
reads a half second,
my clock reads one second.
When your clock
reads one second,
my clock reads two seconds.
You would say that my
clocks were reading fast
if we just made that
direct comparison.
But at the same time, we know
that's not the right answer.
You should see the
same physics and I see.
If you and I are moving
with respect to each other,
you should see my
clocks running slowly.
So the way out of that is
this question of simultaneity.
From the point of
view of your clocks
going past all my
clocks, if you just
looked at the time on my
clocks as you passed them,
you would actually
think that they
were running fast
relative to your clock.
But you would also,
however, not think
of those clocks were
synchronized with each other.
So you don't
determine what speed
they're running by looking
at two different clocks.
If you want to figure
out whether my clocks
running fast or slow, you want
to look at one of my clocks
and see how it
changes with time,
not comparing different clocks.
Because the different
clocks would just
be out of synchronism with
respect to each other as you
would see it.
And we're not going to
go through the details.
But if you do look at
my clocks consistently
using a family of
your clocks that
are stationary
relative to you, just
as I thought about
a network of clocks
when I was trying to measure
the speed of your clock,
then everything's consistent.
You would see all my
clocks running slowly.
I would see all of your
And because we disagree
on what's simultaneous,
there are no contradictions.
So simultaneity is
absolutely crucial
to get out of what
would otherwise
be a glaring contradiction
in the whole system.
OK, that's about all I
really wanted to say today.
But let me just give
a preview of things
that we'll talk about later
in the course concerning
relativity.
So far I think we've said
all we are going to say,
unless the questions.
I think we've said
all we're going
to say about the
kinematic consequences
of special relativity.
And we're not going to be trying
to derive them, as I said.
If you're interested,
by the way,
the notes recommend
several references,
including the lecture
notes from eight to 86
from earlier years when
special relativity was
included as a real topic.
So certainly if you're
interested in learning
about this and you
haven't already seen it,
I'm happy to help you.
But otherwise, it will
not be part of this course
to discuss how these
three consequences
of special relativity arise
from the basic postulates
of special relativity.
But later we will be saying
things that follow further
along the line by
pursuing the consequences
of special relativity
for momentum and energy,
which will be important to us.
The connection is the
important connection
and simple connection
that energy and momentum
are only interesting
to us if they're
defined in a way which makes
them conserved quantities.
That's why energy and momentum
are important in physics.
Because for a closed
system, the total energy
and the total momentum
do not change.
Energy and momentum
can be transferred
from one part of a
system to another.
But energy and momentum cannot
be either made nor destroyed.
Now if we took Newton's
definitions of energy
and momentum, and used
relativistic kinematics, what
we would find is
that if we looked
at, say, a collision
of two particles,
the Newtonian definitions
of energy and momentum,
if we took those
seriously, would tell us
what might happen
in a collision.
Usually there's an angle
that's undetermined.
But given an angle, it
determines everything else.
If we used special
relativity to then describe
what that same collision would
look like in a different frame,
we would find that these
Newtonian definitions of energy
and momentum would not be
conserved in the other frame,
if they were conserved
in the first frame.
The conservation laws
are dependent on what
reference frame you're using.
So what Einstein
amended was slightly
modified definitions of
energy and momentum, which
are determined by the criterion
that these slightly modified
definitions of energy
and momentum should,
if they are conserved
in one frame
be also concerned in
any other frame, which
are related by the relationships
to special relativity.
So that's why it was
essential once one changed
the kinematics of going
from one frame to another
to also change the definitions
of energy and momentum
so that the conservation laws
would hold in all frames using
the new transformation equations
to get from frame to frame.
And that's why
later in the course
we will be introducing a
slightly modified, slightly
non-Newtonian, definitions
of energy and momentum
of moving particles.
OK, that's all for today.
I will see folks next Tuesday.